London braucht Ordnung
Wir sind die Ordnung
Bei Albion kannst auch du
einen Beitrag für unser Land leisten
Dedsec sei eine größe Gefahr für England warnte der Albion CEO Nigel Cass in der heutigen Pressekonferenz in London
Halt die Klappe
Die illegale Hackergruppe nannte er ein weiteres mal
eine Bande Krimineller die man einsperren müsse. Cass forderte
Willkommen bei Southwark FC gegen die Kensington Rovers.
Und hier die Aufstellungen
Na endlich
Hey, Stevie. Ich hol mir mal was zu trinken.
Passt du so lange auf meinen Platz auf
Kein Problem
Vorsicht junge Dame. Sonst verpassen sie noch das
Match, weil ich sie ins Krankenhaus fahren muss
Das Derby gegen die Loser aus Kensington, das würde ich nicht mal auf meinem Totenbett verpassen.
Männer. Mir ist heute meine Transportdrohne kaputt gegangen
und da musste ich doch ernsthaft hier
zu Fuss hin latschen
Ich dreh durch, Ich dreh durch. Prost, Sheila
Gerne wieder
Eine Whisky. Den Besten, bitte
Prost
Ladies und Gentlemen. Routinekontrolle
Ihr kennt das ja alle. Schön locker bleiben,
alle Fragen beantworten, dann wird keinem waspassieren.
Und keiner verlässt den Laden, kapiert.
Das ist ein Nichtraucherpub.
Und was willst du dagegen machen?
Wir sind das Gesetz.
Kensington im Angriff. Pass auf die Seite, Flanke, Schuss...
Aber knapp vorbei.
Meine geliebten Rovers. Heute gibts sowas von auf
den Sack für Southwark.
Ohrr. Da stinkt aber jemand gewaltig.
Haben die kein Deo auf der Baustelle.
Halt die Fresse.
Du willst doch nichts sagen, was michoder meine Jungs verärgern könnte.
Hinsetzen. Komm.
Das ist aber ein edler Tropfen. Gibt es was zu feiern?
Wenn man nichts Nettes zu sagen
hat sollte, man besser gar nichts sagen.
Ok genug Smalltalk. Ein Vögelchen
hat mir gezwitschert, dass in diesem
Drecksloch gelegentlich Dedsecabschaum ein und ausgeht .
Wer voneuch jämmerlichen Losern kann mir was darüber erzählen.
Du?
Du? Du?
Ihr?
Gut. Dann die harte Tour.
Kleine Gesundheitsinfo. Wenn sie ein
Jahr lang rauchen, verkürzt sich ihre
Lebensdauer um drei Monate. Ich verkürz
gleich deine Lebensdauer wenn du weiter den
Oberlehrer spielst.
Das war doch nur ein kleiner Spaß. Sie wollen doch sicher auch die blühende Zukunft unseres
wunderschönen Landes Großbritannien selbst miterleben, oder?
Hör ich da so bisschen versteckte Kritik.
Hat hier sonst noch irgendjemand was
auszusetzen an Albion, eurem Freund und
Helfer.
Außer natürlich gehört zu Dedsec.
Weitere Gesundheitsinfo.
Rauchen verursacht Mundgeruch.
Durchsucht diesen kleinen Wichser. Vielleicht gehört er auch zu Dedsec.
Heutzutage kann man ja nie wissen.